uh the deputy reported the mail informed
him that he was under the influence of
PCP cocaine and methamphetamine sure
that's a cocktail that's called
something that's the trifecta I mean
yeah there's a Navy slappingers yeah
it's always got some weird baby slab
cookie punching
stick around
hey daddies welcome to another episode
of dumb people Town population
you know there are people in this
business who I feel like if we all lived
in New York we would be hanging out a
lot more but when we see you at a
festival that make that feels like okay
I'm here it started this is our time to
get we have such great times like you
are the reason one of the main reasons
why when I go to moon tower you and all
of our New York people who we come
together there Dan is it and we're going
to be back in a month we met at um the
Conan pop-up shows at Comic-Con on San
Diego yeah that was like 2018 or seventh
yeah that was my uh
yeah maybe 17 maybe but that was the
funniest it took me years to ever
try a uh like a bird or scootering again
because I think I just got a bunk one
but how it felt like I was in that
populated Street going down yeah yeah
you're not supposed to ride them on
Cobblestone bro it wasn't Cobblestone it
was regular Flat Road and I gave it a
few pushes and pushed the button and it
just wasn't gonna put both my feet on it
wasn't going and then I would take one
of my feet off and it would start to
take off and I would be like I'm losing
so I'm embarrassed and I thought I was
too heavy for the scooter no come on did
I just regular scootered it the whole
way
profuse sweat yeah of course there's
also some resistance there because
there's that guy with a razor I mean I
mean really they push it he was the old
one I was like no no I prefer it this
way
I'm not too fat for it to work it's
definitely I prefer it like this is a
workout I'm getting my steps in well I
love that that because you feel stupid
and in this world seeing that if we were
to see that we're like all right this is
this is a dumb thing the world's getting
dumber and that's really what this show
is about it's like we get great stories
sent Us by our fans and do four of us
just break them down Jay's got the first
story let's jump into and then we'll
find out and let everybody know what's
going on with you you can tell stories
and all that stuff all right send in by
Kyle Andrews at late night nachos we
love this dude you go wherever you want
with this story okay here we go if it
reminds you a story you hit it if you
want to just make a joke do that if you
have questions we're here for what we
can pose as answers sure man Angry about
sold out flights carjacked multiple
Vehicles police say
and it's also true for the movie falling
down it's never about the flight it's
never about the flight he was talking
about sold out flights it's not about
the breakfast not being served the straw
for sure yeah definitely sure what
they're all sold out why don't they add
more so he's mad that there's sold out
flights so he decides he did the only
thing he could do
he's also going through some sort of
like a Goldilocks complex where each one
doesn't feel right this one's too cold
this one's too this one's a little
foreign
I want to support American workers all
right let's let's get into that Colorado
Man became angry after ticket agents at
the Salt Lake City International Airport
told him he couldn't buy same-day plane
tickets to Denver hold on if you're if
you're at the airport
something is big time
I've never bought them have you ever had
an airplane not once oh I have in a
thing where they all flights were
canceled right yeah you had to walk over
yeah and it seems crazy do you seem like
you want to pay all cash for right back
to a time though the movie like that was
a joke that wasn't over anyone's head
remember the movie Airplane oh yeah that
was the idea that yeah you go to my
butterfly yes I'll have one ticket
please
meet the parents when he's got to buy
the ticket there's that great scene with
Cali Rocco where she just is like typing
forever I give uh
I always give credit to those jokes when
I love that movie when I was a kid
and then the adult jokes I didn't catch
oh all of them when I was younger and
the the best one is uh
is do you have anything uh light because
you want a magazine goes I have this
leaflet famous Jewish sports legend and
I just didn't get the
how much
how about this leaflet leaflet is a
great comedy leaflet is a great one so
it makes it so small so but like you're
at the airport you're behind this guy in
line and you're like oh this dude's
gonna start carjacking yeah
is I'm not gonna tell you how old he is
okay uh but he was under the influence
of drugs surprise always good to buy
plane tickets I gotta get out of here
man it is a plate that is a at the
airport plane ticket purchase yeah State
though you get drugs how [__] up was
Jeff well he went to the airport tried
to buy tickets one way or another he was
getting arrested that day so I mean uh
at uh our Festival skank fest last year
Chris O'Connor
it was a hilarious comic took Molly and
left the festival went to the airport
bought a ticket to Denver
uh went and went to like the woods
and then the next day like uh everyone's
like where is he is it 7 15. well it was
funny he posted like a picture from the
like the woods in a stream somewhere in
Denver or Colorado yeah has anybody
where the main stage
and you see the location that's some
good stuff okay I mean really he thought
it was a and he said when he got there
he was like why the hell did I do this I
had to see some mountains or something
yeah they're hilarious all right so this
guy was how many cars did he carjacked
and then how many more do you try and
steal okay so he storms out right how
many cars a lot of the airport if you're
in a car jack the airport a lot of
standing cars right like people like
dealing with things in the back saying
goodbye I mean do you exactly like as
they're drunk open trunk open you just
take off yeah because the car's still
running at that point right you find
like a a big buck girl wearing some
juicy sweatpants yes I would make it out
with a guy
that's what I mean she said what
what you lesbians bring flowers on a
first date and a U-Haul on the second
that's right
my Rochelle Illinois life had never
heard again you're being enlightened
there you go Dan you're understanding
all right so how many cars did he try
and carjack he tried to Jack seven cars
and then he stole he wound up stealing
three
and when you say Jack it's like he
gunpoint I took over someone's car and
then a company stole their whatever they
were like trying or pulled it from them
yeah
um where was his destination he was
trying to get to he's going trying to
get to Colorado he was at the Salt Lake
City Airport Salt Lake City Colorado a
couple hours so he's stealing two two
car checkings one steal what do I feel
like in some carjackings one steal a lot
of people are like you can have it
um
I'm gonna go
uh he carjacked two cars and tried to
steal two more oh
Chuck Woolery style then he hit several
vehicles in Salt Lake and Summit
counties before he was taken into
custody uh so he hit he hit and damaged
Vehicles oh yeah not just stealing cars
he hit other cars
this guy's name John Joseph Thomas Green
Jingleheimer Schmidt his name is my name
too yeah want to say it again John John
Joseph Thomas Green his name is
whenever I go out to people choose to
shout yeah John Joseph
the amount of charge calling out a
foursome for golf
John who's coming John Joseph Thomas and
green yeah uh our parents gave him every
basic name well they were hoping he
would be himself a law firm each name
needed a car yeah right then yeah two
jackings John Joseph Thomas and Grayson
green all right so uh he was butching
the Summit County jail for investigation
of aggravated robbery DUI aggravated
assault assault threat of violence
driving a stolen vehicle reckless
driving failure to remain the scene of
an accident and other potential charges
this is what I'm saying this they
couldn't have given this guy an exit row
like over book it over book it and get
someone to bump somebody I'm gonna tell
that story again do the uh the time to
kill where you go that picture he's
white
all right the wild morning began what
city 5 a.m when Salt Lake City police
received information about a um we'll
tell you we'll guess his age at the end
who became combative at the airport yeah
there are a lot of people that get angry
at the airport police reported that the
airport like makes people angry
sometimes larger women the TSA just
screams at you as though you've been
there before no the TSA screams at you
in a way that like you're like oh you're
at the end you know everyone there who's
at the end of their shift they yell at
you sometimes like you're defusing a
bomb don't put the thing get grab the
trash only gonna tell you one more time
in New York though they've also figured
out like they look like video hoes so
they're yelling at you and they've got
like
corset waists and like these crazy
don't push it forward you know there's
nasty right I also hate the news for
this abuse all of our frequent flyers
and Comics yeah the new ones where you
have to wait for the bin to come to you
grab that bin and you see your bin and
then you have to wait for the next one
and Meanwhile your first bin is gone
yeah and now you're standing like well
can I keep my items to you no so I'm
like well this is like the end of a John
Wick movie you're like grab them in he's
falling down get the guy with the cats
TSA and clear and all it's still too
intense there is moments where like for
all this I'd rather just leave the
airport yes
I could do that on my time because
that's on my time by the way carjacked
my way back to Colorado is a song that
John Denver wishes he would have yeah
yeah uh police really know some of the
balls in your court
reportedly that the man had been angry
after a flight got canceled but they
clarified later Friday that he did not
actually have an existing flight
reservation and was unable to obtain a
ticket and became upset so this is my
question do you think and I don't know
if this thing answers it do you think he
was combative in getting upset and then
they're like oh we're not letting this
guy on a plane oh yeah they didn't let
him pass a ticket encounter right I
think he was so drunk he showed up on
the wrong day yes and so he's like my
flight's not here no you aren't on a
flight right right because he said it
was he thought it was canceled which
means he didn't see it on the board and
the airport's like once he left the
doors were like all right he's no longer
that's the Wild's problem thank God we
got rid of that we won't be hearing
about that guy anymore
off our radar operator he's done he'll
be fine as as officers were heading to
the scene they learned that the
passenger had actually left the air I
had carjacked someone at the airport yep
green left the air with the stolen
vehicle crashing into another vehicle
near the intersection of 900 West just
put this on the walking tour and 200
2100 South accordingly I love that it's
900 West we're like we're not even going
to finish this Street Northwest 2100
South according to Weisberg the man then
made a u-turn and allegedly crashed into
a second car yeah green then tried to
steal an SUV and the female driver who
was wearing her seatbelt pushed the man
away and told him to get away from her
as she tried to pull as he tried to pull
her from the seat he gave up so she
fought him off like a bear and one yeah
yeah he's like literally that's the
cocaine bear you fight that thing off
and you move forward Jesus he gave up
and took another car that he had taken
it took the car that he had taken the
airport then he got on the freeway
towards South South Lake uh Salt Lake
where he hit another vehicle and nearly
crashed into a building at 2860
Southwest Temple this guy is going on a
spring yeah the plan wouldn't have been
awful if he knew how to I think right so
that might be it had he just carjacked a
car and just gone to Colorado I thought
he was changing cars for like like ass
or something or to avoid the police hey
we got a southbound this one
he would smash himself he was just
demolition Durham until it was over he
had Allen Iverson in the car I'm done
with it now let's just get another one
green then drove the Dodge Durango East
on I-80 and is accused of causing how
many crashes oh wow I think it in
addition to the ones yeah this is this
is on i-83 I think seven I'm going my
gut was going to say seven I'll go eight
you go seven I'll go eight five wow five
crashes
but that's eight for the day yeah
three people
we'll add the couple before I thought
there was like seven or eight oh these
people are completely yeah this guy's
not doing that watch this news this
after the stolen vehicle was disabled in
the fifth crash the man tried to carjack
more vehicles on the eastbound side of
traffic Rhoden said but he was
unsuccessful in those efforts yeah so
cars are coming there's a guy in the
street waving you down
the man then got into the westbound
lanes and throat started throwing rocks
hitting a truck yeah this guy is going
all out this guy is doing this is what I
would
yeah they really should be like if you
put like a bubbly
little Montage tune over it looks like
fun things
I cited it earlier it does feel like the
reboot like this year's falling down
yeah like this is this first I mean I
would put dude
smashing cars you see like a fire plug
and he's like
he tries to carjack the woman and she
pushed him away and as she's driving
away he's like
dude
or this does feel she goes he's got the
car and she goes it's in neutral you
know she forces it it puts in drive and
she goes
this guy is this a new Grand Theft Auto
like what's up how many points would you
would he get in Grand Theft Auto well
you get four stars yeah exactly four
stars four stars okay uh helicopters the
driver the truck stopped obviously when
he threw a rock at his windshield his
driver's drug is like I'm gonna go get
this guy what else has this guy done
today sure yeah this guy's clearly
throwing rocks at passing cars I'll sort
this [__] out uh approached him I mean
the amount of speed that that guy's
probably yeah he's like driving a truck
so much speed cursing through my veins
I'm gonna take it out I was fighting
with Red Bull Wings yeah it's like I
just I just Red Bull games
that's the two truckers in the air
fighting with it yeah holographic it's
like four feet off the ground and then
arm wrestling for custody of their kid
that's right
you turn it over the top oh yeah that
movie rules it does it's just an arm
wrestling contest for custody I mean
that should hold up in court right yeah
for sure uh this guy green approached
this trucker and uh guy driving the
truck and stayed that he was going to
kill the driver thank you the suspect
got into a physical altercation with the
driver because you know when someone
says I'm going to kill you the next
thing you do is start fighting get into
it let's get into it and then proceeded
to enter the pickup through the driver's
door Rhoden said the owner removed the
keys from the ignition which prevented
the man from taking it to Summit County
Sheriff deputies and arrived and pull
Green from the pickup and safely took
him into custody at about what time
translation stepped on us this is all
1pm 1 p.m so it started at 5 a.m sorry 5
a.m oh it started at five uh what time
is this happening the 8 A.M 8 A.M for
three hours
to say nine I was right there in the
middle 6 15 a.m this guy has done more
hour and a half before you wake up than
the Army we do more before you before
the flight hasn't left yet
what if he carjacked that and went
straight back to the airport he's like I
need to get ready
endo and try to climb up the yeah climb
up the wheel yeah by the way this what
if this is like you know part that one
half of the greatest rom-com ever he's
like by any way I'm gonna get to the
girl her she's on this flight she's on
the flight I'm destined to be there
she's gonna go study abroad but I have
to tell her I love her when we first met
we hated each other and then it took
about 80 minutes for us to love each
other Miss get
I will kill you or die of a broken heart
uh the deputy reported the male informed
him that he was under the influence of
PCP cocaine or Methamphetamine sure
that's a cocktail that's called
something that's the trifecta I mean
yeah there's a baby slapping her yeah
it's always got some weird baby slab
cookie punching
this guy was straight up Cookie punching
that's great oh you say meth coconut
yeah that's cookie
yeah that's at least a car jack uh green
who deputy said has a Colorado driver's
license was taken to Park City Medical
Center before he was booked into jail
while at the hospital a trooper reported
that green was talking to himself
incoherently sure it delayed motor
functions and had a thousand yard stare
green had difficulty following simple
instructions and struggled to answer
basic questions according to the
affidavit now we will guess but he was
TSA Pre he was foreign
by 6 15 a.m
it's either early end of 20s yep or late
40s or early 50s so go with something
just grab a number and it's yours
24 24. I like that I'm gonna go 26 26.
I'll go the other side I think he's 57.
wow yeah get your answers in townies I
mean he's at the end of a meth the heads
or the beginning or the beginning of
like the next chapter
get your answers in shout out your ham
radios whatever you're listening to the
song okay
Thomas Green who was eating a cookie
punch he did a cookie punch and then he
did a whole lot of the cookies
on everything but the bagel he was he
was 20 years old
baby you were very close you know you're
crazy you know you're crazy I said he's
really young or old he's not looking at
the future or he realizes this is my
last this is my last shot yeah this is
life all right there you go there you go
Story number one of the Brooks down in
the Brooks and the books uh Big Jay
oakerson is with us he's got podcasts
he's got all kinds of things that you
need to find out about and just talk
about all that on the other side of the
break this is dumb people Town don't go
anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show uh
before we get into how you can support
Big Jay oakerson and you should
um we want to remind people I'm not sure
exactly when this is dropping I'm not
sure when this is going to drop either
so it may have it may drop after we were
at moon tower and what a wonderful moon
tower we had with you all right it was
the best we did the living wake of uh we
only uh we only had to carjack two
people only two people so who knows
maybe this will happen before if we
wanted to this could happen before
the living wake of big jokerson which is
going to be amazing it's really one of
the coolest shows ever and I'm so happy
for for someone who has so many people
who love him so much and I'm sure people
tell you this all the time but to be
able to sit there and hear your friends
outpour the love for you it's a really
beautiful it's a beautiful life we've
watched all the ones that you guys have
done we've been a part of them yeah
they've been amazing you guys did the
Odin Kirk one and the Chris red one
they're just it's a cool it's a really
cool thing he cried he did I mean and he
came into it going I don't know why
we're doing this and by the end of it he
cried he's like I was overcome by him
we're pitching it as a show and we use
he said at the end he's like comedy
needs this show yeah I was like well
that's going in yeah that's it we're
gonna do a dumb people town too we've
got Dulce Sloan who is fantastic Natalie
Natalie palomides it's gonna be so much
fun we're doing tag it which is such a
fun show where our friends go up and do
stand up and then we are on the side
like writing jokes and pitches to pitch
to them so we're doing that in a great
list of people are doing Dana Gould's
doing that I mean there's so many fun
great it's a super fun show and then uh
we're doing the Comedy Jam every night
so every night very excited uh all right
so all that happening without explaining
to somebody
last night at The Comedy Store the the
constant call back
centerfold so good in other songs
[Applause]
uh we're gonna crack out some new ones
this time it's gonna be really fun too
uh yeah I just love it so much again
it's like pure fun hanging with your
friends doing a Comedy Festival that
people love that's in Austin third week
and then third week of uh May Randy and
I are going to be in Minneapolis at the
Acme Comedy Club with true love so right
love that uh and uh that's
superscars.com danielvankirk.com yeah
the week after moon tower I'm headlining
in Denver and then uh I should have some
dates in June and uh July everything's
up at danielvankirk.com and then my show
here in town every other Monday with
Irene two that is over at the cat's
crawl you can go to daniel.com all right
Jay people can catch obviously they
listen to bonfire on uh yeah with uh
Robert Kelly yeah
so uh went on he wants to go try some
other stuff so okay great that's a great
it's a great pairing too I love me some
Robert Kelly and then Robert Kelly yeah
like stepped in and it's yeah it's
perfect perfect yeah so far so that's
great that's a great and then do you
have dates this spring uh I'm all over
the place and doing Bert kreischer's
whole tour I'm on the road myself but uh
April 5th uh is my special dog bellies
coming out so it's out right now yeah uh
self-produced so great please check it
out search it comment you guys this is
one of our favorite Comics easily like
one of the best one of the most present
comments ever the best in the moment
Comics we've ever worked with and ever
seen support this guy watch his special
leave you know positive comments and
whatnot and share it share it with a
friend send a link this is how guys like
this who we love get to make more of
these things and when it does really
well like a guy like Sam Ariel special
did like boom it goes to another place
so fingers crossed Ari shaffir his was
great executive produced it I used
basically his crew that he lined up and
he was so so helpful and
you know he his thing for like the venmo
and paper you know the donation yeah it
has like a heartfelt like you know this
is uh my life's work and I put like you
know half my life savings into this and
blah blah blah
you know give back so we can continue to
do things like this that's right
absolutely and uh I said and Ari's like
yeah you got to put it up there and I'm
like it's so like not myself but I just
hope I go okay I'll put it up and I'm
gonna go I think this is tacky but Ari
said I have to
I think it's Tech
and then by the way if it makes a bunch
of money I'll be like nice
well support well so so so everything's
up on the YouTube channel it's on your
YouTube channel big jokerson big jail
Christian you should just subscribe to
that Channel watch this special as we
said and if you feel like hey I just
watched entertainment and I'm going to
donate a little cash do that do it it's
worth it it means so much to the
comments like us who are trying to to do
it on our own so yeah all right dog
belly that's it all right I love it all
right Dan let's jump into this ready yes
this was sent in by gromsky at Mike
movie snob
I think there's a first time for this
person sending in so our fans send them
in they just tweet at us which is really
the best way to do it and it's hashtag
dumb people tone tweeted it's Cloud
Brothers Danny Van Kirk we have a
backlog right we have so we're we are so
backlogged I just put like six nude
stories in the document in the big
document and we're not even through like
the middle of November yet I should also
say if this is coming out shortly after
your special has premiered and before
we're all at moon tower it is it is we
will have a Greenly for the lives like
this dude in Florida who he doesn't do
them anymore but he would write the
craziest non-sequiturs in his news
coverage like he explained what pants
were yeah yeah what a hand is yeah like
like comedy or is it just his no no this
is this is just a reporter who writes
the story so he stopped doing it but uh
I found some backlog ones so we'll have
one we have it really hey uh is this
coming out on the 11th
so his specialist came out tomorrow
night on the 12th at The Comedy Store in
the belly room we're doing a tag yeah
and I'm on it and this and we have all
this stuff and on the this weekend on
the 14th I'll be in Houston doing the
would you rather comedy show with Andrew
Youngblood okay yeah
here's the headline Grandma's dying wish
was a giant dick on her grave what is it
it's exactly what you think do you put
like a cardboard cut out of Dick Van
Patten just Mexico City before her death
grandmother Katrina orduna Perez had one
final wish a giant put a statue put a
dick a penis on the top of her grave so
she was like a Perpetual bachelorette
party I don't understand dick headstone
her family unveiled the completed
Monument mounted on her Tomb at a
cemetery in Mexico this past weekend as
quote a recognition of her love and joy
for life so this is like one of those
requests that after someone dies you're
like they're never gonna know this is
where you start believing in nihilism
wait you're saying you don't lady well
that's the next thing I'm gonna get into
it but you don't you're saying you don't
have to do it because they'll never know
but if you go to the cemetery I mean
we've gone to the cemetery for our
fathers you know where it is generally
or if you're looking for somebody you
haven't found before yeah
look when you see the huge dick well
hang on a second is it circumcised but
no now everyone everyone around her can
use the dick as a beacon we're three
over from the giant dick we're still in
the shadow of it and the dick can serve
as a sundial so when the sun's out what
time is it
how old do you guys think she is what
grandma what age do you think this is
also don't you feel like you 45. you
love it uh you have to I'm right you
have to get her on camera or in writing
because No One's Gonna believe you no
she wants this I say 61. 61. what do you
think uh NADA you're gonna have to throw
that down in writing yeah yeah they're
gonna say or at least draw a sketch
especially with us they'd be like real
nice Jason
throw the date right because they would
look at you and be like we're doing a
bet for Grandma's funeral that's how
we're gonna that's how we're gonna treat
this so adult people at their funerals
like sometimes as like a gag will like
as soon as you start talking about me
press this button and there'll be a tape
player and it'll be my voice
hey guys I'm still in here we had a we
did a story once a guy someone has done
something like that this hologram
uh no but that is to me this is like a
lasting final joke practical joke so I'm
gonna say she was 70 years old seven
years old because I think old people now
are resembling young like 70 years old
sounds old but you know you're a few
years old in Rich Falls yeah that's
right
and that's something he would do oh
totally
put a dick on Donnie on Bonnie
McFarland's grade this grandma is was 99
years old
99. she can do whatever she wants see
this changes it for me 99 you can do
whatever you want this is it you want a
dick on Your Grave 99 you got 99 years
and a dick ain't one that's right I have
to guess
this is a dementia plan
that everyone endorsed the people around
her just didn't fully understand sure
sure maybe Cialis is paying for her
funeral
if I do this it fully her grandson told
Vice world news quote she wanted to
break the Paradigm of everything Mexican
where things are sometimes hidden
because of not having an open mind she
was always very avant-garde very forward
thinking about things so like everything
is Mexican is my favorite song from The
Lego Movie right everything is Mexican
and everything is cool when the Dick's
on Your Grave Donna Kata as she's
lovingly known throughout the small town
we're like yeah
in the Eastern State of Veracruz had a
particular affinity for penises and what
she believed they represented she always
said in the Mexican sense they were
virgas V e-r-g-a-s Very Yes said her
grandson olivaro Moda lemon hey she's
like and then her grandson's like hey
Grandma don't talk about me in the same
sentence this is Dicks there are a few
words in Mexico
87.
he's at least if you tell me that
at least 45. there are a few words in
Mexican slang as dynamic as virga which
is perhaps best translated in English as
[__] due to its General use of profanity
depending on how it's phrased virga can
be a brutal it's just like this awesome
dirty old lady who lives
the new symbol of the Legion of skanks
telling the herd
Flags engraved she's your Evita no she's
your sister uh for Loyola
yes she's your sister Gene she's the
legionist people like why do you guys
sound shirts with an old woman
she's a Visionary she's our patron saint
in death she did what we all wanted in
life yeah she actually walked by that
gravestone going to your family's grave
you do have there's a slight knot of
like that chick gets it she gets it
Virgo can be a brutal insult telling
someone to go [__] themselves right yeah
I will try this
or it can be a compliment a badge of
honor yet if something is Virgo it's
cool or badass so that's what I guess
she leaned in on yeah exactly one way or
another all right
I think it's leaning down on Donna Kata
backed up into donakana instilled the
message to her children grandchildren
and great-grandchildren that they were
virgas or and could accomplish whatever
they wanted what if she's just telling
only her family to go [__] themselves
and they're like you love us because
we're badasses that's the size of this
thing I'm gonna show you the photos
coming out of the ground they can
accomplish whatever they wanted
especially the women in a country
steeped in machismo you said her
grandson many members of the family went
on to wide-ranging careers that's great
Moto Limon recalled how his grandmother
saw life with great optimism and that
problems shouldn't overwhelm us okay we
conceptualized that idea to the family
one thing with the metaphor of a penis
meaning you're a virga or one should not
give up when problems arose you needed
to face them head on there's so many
yeah exactly I don't think there are any
of them around I mean just one eye keep
one eye open and always be prepared to
grow on a logistical level
it's got to be too big to [__] oh no no
oh you mean so that people won't come to
the grave and sit down no it's it's got
to be enormous yeah I mean to me it
should be bigger and if it's got to be
big enough that if you do get inside you
you earned it you earned it number one
and number two you get it inside of you
I'm going to show you this it should be
big enough that you could play a ring
toss with it just as a game but it
should be something
oh my God
expect it to be uh color correct and I
did not expect it to be like full marble
it is a monument uh the poor guy's gonna
drag it there's just he's like there's
no other way to drag it or he gets to
it's the only way it fits too I'll take
this one you guys want me to drag me a
giant wiener over it goes full to the
base like it's flared at the end so they
didn't even say they forgot to leave out
there's also balls yeah it is it is so
anatomical it's got a vein to it I don't
know why I pictured it being more like
uh like a gun table like you know when
you get the oak tree yeah
like a super thick ridiculously like
almost artistic I didn't realize it was
going to be a giant Pink wiener to me if
like if Playboy ever had like a Sky Mall
I feel like that would be it it's like
the Sasquatch
Stone the Brookstone
a Rob Gronkowski back massager and a uh
and put this on your grave that's a 28
foot cake
over the years Donna Kata had if I'm
saying anything wrong I'm trying uh had
told her family and people around her
town that when she died she wanted her
tomb adorned with a penis her grandson
thought it was just Grandma being
Grandma bold spunky and playful as
always he didn't think she was a serious
spunky as a word well no no but I I do
believe this like Jay and I saw Mel
Brooks speak at like a screening of
Blazing Saddles in Denver and he was
funny we met him afterwards and we
talked to him he was funny he was on it
he was 94 years old when this happened
it was a couple years ago he I believe
his mischieviousness his tits but that
allowed him to live and and live in that
way so I believe that this woman's
spunkiness or whatever you want to call
it like the fact that she has an edge to
her I believe that is what caused her
before she died so I think she was a
happy lady yeah to lay that joke out I I
love this like to see how huge it is I
think it is before she died her grandson
asked her like was she serious about
this long series quote she told me that
it was her desire that no one would
forget her and that everything we loved
about her would be remembered more
easily after Donna caught his death we
talked as a family and decided to make
her dream come true
well it took a while to put the process
in motion I mean it's definitely
something that like you bring your kids
to the gravesite kids get off the balls
stop climbing on the shaft guys come on
I think we have to go put stones on it
and grass out of respect put two stones
on each Stone just stick the flowers
right and stick it in the tank stick the
flowers I will say it's too big to have
sex with for sure for sure but it's not
too big for everyone who goes past that
to maybe fire up a drone and do a lay
down with your legs on either side
exactly exactly yes the overhead oh no
there are several pictures taken with
this the grandson called a local
engineer in town who builds Plastic
Products like water tanks and children's
playsets and asked if he was up to the
test to ask at first I thought what
you're working on Jose you're behind the
statue because it's not very common to
see these kinds of sculptures or
monuments and even less so in the memory
of someone who's deceased after he told
them several times that he was serious
he got to work and it took nearly a
month and a team of 12 people including
a carpenter a sander and a sculptor and
a Carver to build the Statue is this the
story of Jesus I'm sorry five and a half
feet tall and weighs anybody want to
guess someone shut down how much do you
think it weighs oh this is a cool
four or five hundred pounds okay oh yeah
I think almost 800 pounds I'm gonna say
2 000 pounds it weighs
600 pounds yeah
uh they got particularly delayed on the
ball sack here we go when the first
attempt was disfigured hey that's just
how God I mean hey sometimes balls are
disfigured and they had to start they
had to start the process your balls are
so great exactly what balls are perfect
uh
uh not everybody's happy about the
Statue of every 10 people I think are on
seven see it positively and if they
don't see it as a good thing they at
least respect her wishes there's others
who in their conservative values are
closed-minded very Square who see it
poorly that's a fascinating number
seven out of ten I thought that would be
and and the other three people uh
respect the yeah the wishes I thought it
was going to be two out of ten when I
thought it was hilarious and one person
only who's more hilarious went yeah
leave it leave it right seven or like
get this thing out of here right I think
the grounds and seven are going I love
it that's right yeah you dug Graves
stand in your eyes
I would assume that someone at the
cemetery has like a giant raincoat and
you got to put it on if like enough
people are complaining if like there's a
funeral happening people walk into the
cemetery like who's that dick that
Cemetery there was not a lot of like jig
monuments I mean
somebody's grieving
well he's standing really erect
uh some people were doing goofy goofy
inscriptions and stuff but that's it uh
that's Story number two damn um I know
oh here this is this is the grandma by
the way
she's loving life guys I love her look
at that hat that hat is like hey look at
her smile yeah she was a dirty old lady
until the day she died yeah bury me with
a big dick I love everything about her
all right Randy gonna tease us a little
bit on Story three okay so this story
that we're gonna do in Story Three is
the silly story that gets treated deadly
serious and gets resolved in the
silliest of ways that is happening after
the break Big Jay oakerson is with us
his new special dog belly is out on
YouTube he put it out go watch it go
support it this is how we support
independent Comics do it we'll be right
back after this
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the show take
us home I'm gonna take you guys home
this final story was sent to us by Jade
at
jdbaby12. that's a new person too yeah
by 12. all right again like I said just
to recap silly story that gets treated
deadly seriously then gets resolved in
the silliest of ways here we go here's
the headline Florida man who allegedly
threatened family with Coldplay lyrics
and standoff after SWAT promises him
Pizza
so it starts with the threat of I'm
gonna use I'm gonna threaten you with
Coldplay lyrics and then it the SWAT
team comes what's the threat there I
mean Have you listened to Coldplay
recently
yellow over and over again by the way I
just read in our article Dan an article
came across my feed recently that says
this is a this is a news article
that Chris Martin no longer eats dinner
I'm like why is this [__] I saw that
too Chris Martin no longer eats dinner
that's news by the way that was reported
on time to go she went took some
mushrooms went to go see Coldplay and
Christine and Josh out of Myers yes and
we had a it was was it so good I'm sure
it was okay I mean I'm sure they give
you a bracelet and your part like oh
yeah it lights up but it's also like on
a program where it's like it makes like
you're part of like designs it's not
just lighting up in different colors
like you sitting here people make a
heart like it knows if you're in that
area you're part of like a heart oh my
God and people were it was a perfectly
on mushrooms because it's all laughably
so lame yeah hindsight yes but there was
the people that were dancing on these
one dance floors were making
like kinetic energy for the stadium Iran
like the things powered by people on
bike you can go ride the exercise bike
for a while that's powering the stage
it's like as soon as you leave you're
like was I like did somebody house me in
there like it wasn't that's not my scene
I love hearing that and everybody walks
out with a vagina scented candle just as
a anyway all right so trying to move
these things
we can't put anything else in the goop
offices [__] makes uh [__] candles
that leaves
all right a Florida man accused of
threatening his family by texting them
Coldplay lyrics I mean this is like oh
Jesus this is it and and warning them of
Retribution from his Nazi prison
associates oh by the way I didn't
realize there was a Nazi called Nazi
Coldplay connection I don't think there
is I know there is now listen Adolf I'm
gonna shoot over the lyrics first and
see if that does the trick if not I
might need to bring in the muscle well
the one thing about the Nazis and
Coldplay very obsessed with clocks all
right so
I think Chris Martin would definitely be
on a teenage Hitler poster in his room
yeah exactly right I could see him with
he's like anyway I was persuaded by
police to end the standoff in return for
and we've talked about this all the time
a FR a fresh slice of pizza one slice so
Jay's friend stopped her because my
friend was a cop my friend's friend was
a cop and I was at a birthday party for
like kids and I just like started
talking to this dude that's who you want
to chat I want to hear that every story
right he's like if you took away my gun
and my Taser and replaced the trunk of
my car just filled it up filled it up
with snack size bags of Doritos he's
like I could solve everything I could
solve every crime in the city you guys
got a knife in his way hey man why don't
I take that I'll give you let me give
you this bag of Doritos give me the
knife you take these Doritos we'll sit
down and we'll talk about it he's like
we've confused he's like it works every
time he's like I'm waiting for it not to
work it works every guy's got a broken
glass like broke the top of a bottle
he's threatening people with it hey man
here take this I'll take that yeah you
don't even tell him he's a commercial
take these two reasons does it work with
Cool Ranch he's like it might but he's
like he's the original Dorito original
people don't see it more complex like
super rich and salt so he goes I know I
know I know but I'm sorry you want me to
trust you you got to trust me yeah I'm
telling you yes this was when they put
in your mouth and the cop goes right
right right now you tell me that's not
worth putting that gun down for it right
let's talk about everything it's a child
all right she was gonna leave anyway
take another bite of that thing
Evan Charles McLemore that's this guy's
name a phenomenal name you told me that
was the rapper's name yeah his whole
name was Heaven Charles until you said
that I wasn't sure it wasn't I'm like
under the belief that a SWAT team
negotiators were ready to hand him one
of America's favorite foods so they
didn't they said we're going to give it
to you and then they lied about the
pizza it's in the it's in the back of
this car this the bend your head down
and put your hands behind the back so
you can eat this pizza
seriously you got to eat no hands it's a
challenge hands behind your back put
your face down you're gonna be on Food
Network was taken into uh cousin Tuesday
following a how long of a confrontation
at a Pensacola home how long was it six
hours six hours what do you think Jay 10
hours
uh
we did one so far six ten ten six and
ten I'm gonna say I'm gonna go less four
okay one of you is exactly right oh it's
six so now we get to play the game do
you think that you're a writer do you
want to hop to another so he's staying
where he is are you gonna stay where you
are
I'm gonna go to 10. I'm gonna go to ten
get your answers in okay
because he was taken in custody Tuesday
following a four hour
never underestimate the power of pizza
with flavored crust all right all right
easy like what's what with flavors it
should all be flavored garlic I
shouldn't like yeah I think you should
take away
if you're trying to use it as bargaining
Pizza yeah you got to go Bare Bones yeah
types pepperoni yeah at the most top
sausage not even a sauce
sausages I wouldn't even do I wouldn't
even go mushrooms because I like
mushrooms
mushrooms would be the thing they'll
probably the difference between me
giving the gun or not with a little
pepper you can't negotiate with
mushrooms you can start an argument with
mushrooms but yeah but you have to
finish one with mushrooms pepperoni is
not gonna be I think but you just get a
a phenomenal treat slice forget it with
a good you could solve world hunger all
right so listen the Pensacola Police
Department wrote on Facebook of course
because that's where they do all their
best comedy writing while adding
officers officers quote cannot comment
on the rumors about pineapple being on
said Pizza operational security and all
that so now they're doing comedy they're
doing business they're doing bits great
it was not immediately clear if
responding officers even gave me so if
you have a negotiation and you send a
pizza in with pineapple and I like
pineapple on a pizza you go you that's a
[__] you that's like saying we don't
even we're not like Ryan you know you
didn't want pizza did you right
pineapple and anchovier too like you've
made a serious decision if you put both
of those on there exactly you're making
a you're making a call no you're the
person you're on a storm the house if
you do that you're hoping yeah like
we're coming in with the bullets and
shields next that's like when people
used to order half anchovy pizza in half
and you're like it's all yeah it doesn't
matter it's permeation it's gotten
everywhere smell is yeah all over it so
the person who orders that pizza is the
person who's like I'll order for the
table and you're like whoa I see things
in here that I like too yeah I don't
trust you to get the things that you're
ordering for you I love calamarios you
don't want that
hang on a second yeah but they did
deliver it so this is the they didn't
deliver if they delivered in the slice
but they did deliver them charges of
resisting an officer without a violence
and aggravated stalking according the
Pensacola News Journal newspaper said
the incident unfolded after police
initially responded to a call about a
possible battery and reportedly learned
McLemore had barricaded himself inside
of a room in his home probably listening
to Coldplay suspect added that he had
called out that he had a gun to his head
he was not going back to prison no
matter what it took after numerous
attempts to lure McLemore out of the
room it proved unsuccessful SWAT was
called in and they deployed the big guns
the promise of pizza probably the rest
he wanted for police for aggravated
stalking this is what they said it's
just he's a bad guy but they got him he
didn't exactly in jail those same people
he goes
it's like are they you know it was you
know they're like yo is that pizza code
for my family wouldn't text me back so
Macklemore's uh family eventually cut
off Communications but not before he
sent it sounds like one text with the
Coldplay lyrics do you want to guess
what the lyric was guess the lyrics you
might be more can you give the salt I
mean it's fair you get the song we can
figure out which well I mean is it is it
a hit is fix you a hit all right yeah
okay yeah we'll try that's all I know
cut to you right now try to fix you cut
to Jay at the concert crying while
they're playing fiction
train doing Drops of Jupiter come on man
so let me say about just passed though
and that happened so let me say if
Coldplay is smart they will read this
article and the next time you go to a
Coldplay concert when they're playing
Fix You giant shape of pizza all right
also very appropriate all the all the
wristbands get you pizza because nothing
is going to fix it here's the lyrics I
think they should lean super into it
like it's like Black Sabbath and Judas
Priest gun show yeah it's going to start
playing fix you have like upside down
crosses going through Panic ramps all
right so it said lights will guide you
home and ignite your bones and I will
try and fix you the lyrics from the song
Fix you're meant to be uplifting it's
unclear how McLemore may have meant them
of course this is not going to make
sense he's barricading himself in his
house I would I would call this a very
cold play by this guy that's what I said
uh police records say uh McLemore has
served an 18-month prison term for
battery of a person over the age of 55
65 his mod he's a terrible guy his bond
has been set at what what is his bond
and we'll get out of here on this [__]
that's a lot yeah what do you think
thirty thousand dollars what do you
think Jay big J the bail yeah
that's uh what are the charges one more
time it's I mean it's battery for uh
threatening people all that 10 hours
yeah
copyright infringement
texting without permission yeah this
guy's gonna be jammed up with Dua Lipa
beat them charges it's an interpolation
it's an interpolation you want me uh
I'll go 50 50k what do you think Jay
um
twenty five to thousand dollars okay get
your answers in townies because and
we'll end it on this big Jay oakerson
dog belly name of the special watch it
right watch it right now if you're
watching this on YouTube you are one
click away and we'll see you guys in
Moontower for the uh if this drops we'll
see if for the uh the wake of big joke
or the living wake of big Jokers and I
can't wait get ready Austin Texas is
going to be great goddamn Comedy Jam
every night we'll be hanging his bond
has been set at
so I started thinking about the hostage
if they're bringing out SWAT yeah when
we go yeah you got to pay for us up in
that Coldplay joke I blame myself
exactly and there you go when we go low
he goes cold he goes cold all right
there you go that is a show you guys we
love you thanks for uh listening to this
show thanks for supporting us and uh
thank you big Joe Christian we love you
no [__] we gotta get back to work
town
[Music]